- Pokemon (beep) rules.
- It's the best.
If you don't like Pokemon, you're wrong.
(upbeat music)
- We're gonna open some
surprise Pokemon gift bags.
I'm very excited.
I've been waiting for this!
- We have been waiting for this!
- For weeks.
- All right.
- Oh, shit!
- Oh!
- Fuck! Okay.
- Oh my gosh, I'm gonna be so embarrassed.
Oh my gosh, you're totally
gonna beat me.
- That's not...
- You know the names of things.
- I don't--
- I just can describe things.
(upbeat music)
- I think it's Red. Yeah.
- Okay, Red.
I think it's red.
(upbeat music)
Okay, so...
- Totodile.
- Totodile, Chikorita...
Cyndaquil.
- [Sydnee] Oh my god.
- Okay, let me count on my hand.
- Wow.
- Hold on, hold on.
- It's so, it's so many now.
- Oh, (beep).
I feel like I'm leaving one out.
- Yeah, I think it's 20
but that feels too round.
I feel like I'm forgetting something.
- I'm gonna say...
17.
(beep)
(groaning)
(upbeat music)
- Psych Up.
- I'm gonna say Psych Up too.
- It's fighting, I think.
(upbeat music)
That is very vague.
- I say Spiritomb.
- And I say Gastly.
(upbeat music)
- Oh my god!
- I--
(groaning)
(upbeat music)
- I wanna say Water, but
I think that's incorrect.
- I'm gonna say Flying/Psychic.
- Dammit, that's right!
- 'Cause I remember,
'cause I was like yeah,
'cause it should be water,
that's what I thought,
- Yeah, that's why,
'cause I was like, I know it's not water.
(upbeat music)
- I'm gonna say Rhyhorn?
Or Rhydon.
Or Mew.
- I'm like, trying to do logic
and think about, like,
what their numbers are.
Which is why I think Mew is a good guess.
- Right, yeah.
- So, like, Charmander,
Squirtle, and Bulbasaur.
(upbeat music)
(chimes)
(cheering)
How did you know this?
(upbeat music)
- I don't, I feel bad,
look at her, she's so sad!
There is so much stuff in this bag.
Oh my god.
Oooh!
- What's that?
- Oh, it's a Pikachu tail!
- Oh my gosh, are you
gonna wear it around?
- A little clutch!
(gasps)
- It's a pencil case!
- Oh, it's a pencil case?
- Have respect.
- Oh, I'm sorry, whoops.
Just look at that.
- Oh my god, that's so cute!
(gasps)
- That's really cool.
- Oh my god!
- That's really, really cool.
(moans)
(gasps)
Just wait.
- Maybe it's like a check.
- Is it a luggage, could
it be a luggage tag?
Oh, I think it is!
- The game should have been
Guess What This Pokemon Paraphernalia Is.
- She woulda won for sure.
(gasps)
- Wait, it's so cute!
(gasps) Look at the little Oddish!
Oh my gosh!
- These are great.
- This is so cool.
- This is really dope.
That's super sick, yeah.
- Oh my gosh.
(upbeat music)